لقد سمعنا جميعًا تعبير الكلب هو
أفضل صديق للرجل ،
ولكن لإنجاح هذه العلاقة ،
يحتاج الناس إلى معرفة كيفية قراءة
لغة جسد الكلب حتى لا يشعروا
بالتهديد
ويهاجمون أو يعضون معظم الكلاب التي
تعض فقط  لذلك لأنهم
خائفون
ويريدون تحذيرك من التراجع ،
فهذا ما يحقق العدوان
المسافة ، لذلك إذا كنت تقابل كلبًا
لأول مرة ،
فإن أهم شيء يجب تذكره هو
إعطائه مساحة
لا تذهب إلى مساحة هذا الكلب ،  لا يزال
الكلب يأتي إليك يقول جيدًا ،
أدر جسمك إلى الجانب بحيث
تبدو أقل تهديدًا ،
ضع يدك في
قبضة يدك وأمسك يدك لأسفل حتى يتمكن الكلب من شم قبضتك
عندما تأكل كلبًا وكذلك لا تحدق
فيه  العيون
لا تبتسم لأن التحديق في
عينيه
يمثل تحديًا ، إنه تهديد الحيوانات الأليفة
على مؤخرة رقبته أو على
ظهره وليس أعلى رأسه تقول إن
التثاؤب ولعق الشفاه قد يكونان علامات
على شعور الكلب  غير
مريح ويريد منك التراجع حاول n  لا
تهرب من كلب أو تصرخ
إذا تم دفعك إلى
كرة استلقِ وقم بتغطية رأسك
عندما يتعلق الأمر بتجنب لدغات الكلاب ،
ومعرفة ما الذي تبحث عنه في
أصدقائنا ذوي الأرجل الأربعة
يمكن أن يساعد كل من الرجل والكلاب في البقاء آمنين
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا هولي
فيفرر